après le débat sur l'abattage des arbres
boulevard heurteloup celui des jets
d'eau de la place jean jaurès plus de
3400 défenseurs du patrimoine ont signé
une pétition en ligne pour ne pas les
détruire lors du tracé de la deuxième
ligne de tramway et tourangeaux sont
visiblement attaché à ce symbole de la
ville une place qui vous allez le voir a
traversé les âges et les événements
depuis sa création
paul boyer ilan chapelet depuis 1856 il
trône en face de l'hôtel de ville
les jets d'eau ont été installés au
coeur de la cité en même temps que l'eau
courante à l'époque c'est un réel
embellissement pour la ville ainsi
qu'une grande prouesse technique
ils ont vu passer des siècles d'histoire
la foule s'y rassemblent à la libération
en 1944 et on y brûle même les drapeaux
nazis dans son tour de france des
départements le 9 mai 1959 de gaulle s'y
arrête et prononce un discours et les
miroirs deux sont encore là un lieu qui
continue d'attirer les foules à chaque
moment important de l'actualité
toutes les manifestations officielles
vont se tenir sur cette place qu'ils
s'agissent de visite de président de la
république comme de gaulle en 1959 la
libération de tours le maire va clamer
la foule du haut des balcons toutes les
grandes manifestations populaires
officielle et et festive
lorsque les tourangeaux fait par exemple
la victoire de la france à la coupe du
monde de foot ça se passe ici est le
public finit dans les jets d'eau
aujourd'hui l'existence de ces jets
d'eau est menacé par le trajet de la
future ligne de tram leur destruction
pourrait intervenir sans difficulté
puisqu'ils ne sont pas classés pourtant
les tourangeaux ne se lasse pas de les
prendre en photo et sont attachés à leur
présence toujours agréable et et tout ça
d'avoir un espace moment un peu vers
quoi parce que tout est bétonné déjà
maintenant avec la première ligne de
tram
yahia lot il ya les fleurs autour c'est
très agréable alors que s'il enlève ça
tout charme de la place sera fichu est
ce que vous êtes oui bien sûr les
fontaines et toutes les fontaines parce
que de plus en plus il ya plus de fronts
ted c'est assez beau architecturalement
et c'est quelque chose de touristique à
tour et donc je trouve ça
vraiment dommage de détruire quelque
chose qui est joli pour juste faire un
tramway chaque tourangeau a forcément
une anecdote en lien avec ses jets d'eau
comme cet étudiant en 2017 qui gardera
un souvenir humide de sa cascade place
jean jaurès